st
george utah terry's with us hi terry how
are you
i'm welcome i'm well dave i'm a little
nervous sorry thank you
for taking my call i've got myself into
a mess
and i get it so you don't even have to
yell
no i know i listen to you i know beans
and rice and all of that here's
quickly um and i can give you as much
detail but bottom line is
i just got a new job but i was without a
dove for two years while i was finishing
my terminal degree
so now i'm a certified nurse midwife i
was a labor and delivery nurse and they
shut down the hospital in my area so i
just kept
doing my schooling so now i'm done but i
lived off student loans and credit cards
so i've got
44 000 in credit card debt 105 in
student loans
but i do own a home and but now i need
to
move because i get i got a new job which
is going to pay me
89 for a year wonderful um
that's the best news so far and i've got
people
right what's that what's the house going
to sell for
it's going to sell it's going to give me
at least 200k
in equity i also have a little rental
property part of it
so um i haven't put it on the market yet
so i i'm bottom line at least 200 it
could go as much as 230k
in equity so but i now have to move
great closer because i'm now new job is
three hours away
great sell it pay off your debt what's
wrong with this plan done
oh not a problem except that i need to
have something to move into
so i was thinking about if i pay off my
credit card
am i i mean i need to have terry
my job terry rent
ah be debt free
start fresh yep you made a mess you have
an
opportunity to clean it up in one fell
swoop
and you're gonna have some money left
over yeah i mean only got 150 out of 230
you got 80 to put down on something if
you wanted to buy something
pay off all your debt don't monkey
around with this
okay and shut down the credit cards
terry shut down the credit cards
uh i've already done that be done i
might have done a silly thing
um i signed up with um greenpath
financial wellness
and they got i'd shut them down um the
credit card
yeah but i if i pay it off then it'll
all be better oh yeah you
you can't hand off the responsibility of
of the mess you created
so those management programs and all of
that that promise they'll handle it for
you
is tell them thanks but no thanks show
your house from powerful you're gonna
pay it off and be done
and matter of fact don't even try to go
by go somewhere and rent for three
months now the biggest fear i have of
this whole thing
is that you next time you feel a little
bit scared or desperate because that's
what happened here
you won't hesitate to go back in debt
because you'll be debt-free and you this
time you won't have a household
yeah so you have to raise your right
hand and swear never again am i going to
use a stupid credit card
never again am i going to say oh i was
forced to buy a car because my car broke
so i got car payments now
never again oh i had to go on vacation
oh my mother was ill so i had to buy an
airline ticket and i had no money
you can never say this crap ever again
you can never rationalize your way back
into debt because you get a clean slate
here
you got to take it and change your ways
permanently you have a 90 000
income you're a rock star you're going
to be in a place to go win
don't stupid's right around every corner
hogan says
waiting it's waiting i've got my right
arm
my right arm is two to square and i
promise because i hate this
okay i hate it well then be 100 free of
it put 80
000 down on something after you rent for
six months in the new neighborhood
so you know the city well before you buy
and
um go pile you up some money make some
money
make some money have no payments and i
want you to get into ramsey plus i'm
gonna give it to you for a year
and i want you to go through financial
peace university and i want you to get
into the
every dollar budgeting app and i want
you to change the way you viewed
money emotionally because money's been
telling you what to do your whole life
and now you're about to tell it what to
do okay
you got it